إذا أنشأنا نسخة سوداء من
Ku Klux Klan وشاهدنا حربًا أهلية كل
جيل مع وجود خلايا إرهابية في كل
غطاء ، وهذا ما يحتاج الأخ ترامب
أن يفهمه لأنه يبدو وكأنه
يحاول الدفع إلى حرب العرق
ولكن الخبر السار هو  إذا كانت هناك حرب عرقية ،
فقد حصلنا على مجموعة كبيرة من
الأخوات الأخوات البيض إلى جانبنا الآن وهذا يحدث فرقًا كبيرًا
ولدينا قوم أسود وقوم أحمر
في الشعوب الأصلية والآسيويين
وما إلى ذلك ، فهذه
مسألة نزاهة وصدق.  من
العدالة والمحبة ، لقد أبقوها على
الأرض المرتفعة ، وكان ذلك شيئًا جميلًا ،
لكنني حطمت الأخ ورأيت
هؤلاء الإخوة يسيرون مثل
المرشد في كنيسة شيلو المعمدانية
ويلتقطون ذلك التابوت ويذهبون ويخرجون من باب منزلي هل
كانوا  لم أستطع أخذها يا رجل ولكن
في هذا لأكثر من 50 عامًا ، ومع
ذلك استعدت للشفاء وسأرتد مرة أخرى
لأننا حصلنا على حب
لا يمكن للعالم أن يسلبه تفوق العالم للبيض
قد يجعل السود جريمة لكننا
نرفض  الحصول على ال  نحن لا نذهب
إلى الأسفل نتأرجح مثل إيلا فيتزجيرالد
محمد علي باسم الحب والعدالة ،
نحن نفعل ذلك من أجل الأخ وايت ونفعل
ذلك من أجل ابنتي ، نحن نفعل ذلك من
أجل الآسيويين ، نحن نفعل ذلك من أجل
عالم بأسره